we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a really important topic i got a
caller who said
is there something about the news
that is bad for one's health
hi david my name is anna um long time
viewer of the show wanted to bring some
female
representation to your voicemail
questions um my question for you is
how do you
protect your mental health while
consuming
so much
just horrible
media yep like
i i feel like my mental health will
suffer just from trying to follow
the world news and follow current events
and i can't imagine what it's like for
somebody that
um
you know does this as their job so i was
wondering how
how you deal with that yeah many people
ask me this so there's two things that
go on one is i'll admit it
you become sort of desensitized to it i
am def there i know when i'm talking to
people not in this business
they will report to me or they will
mention some story in the news
and i can tell i'm not having the
visceral reaction they're having because
i've been desensitized to a lot of this
stuff that's number one but number two
you've got to schedule breaks and uh
when when i'm done producing friday's
show
um until i start getting ready for the
monday show i'm not paying attention to
any news unless there's like some
weekend political event going on that
i'm involved in streaming or whatever
the case may be
and i'm just reading
not politics reading history science
whatever fiction
and doing other things and i think it's
of incredible importance to do that so
the mere fact anna that you're asking
the question
is a very very good sign we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access
to the bonus show